first of all sorry you guys about my
awesome sunglasses wouldn't now wouldn't
you I feel like you can take you Monday
I get the stitches out but I feel let's
take a little gander see how I would
well I wouldn't rock the sunglasses I'm
a little swollen
day three a little small hunty need
sunglasses in here no no I think you're
good I don't like sunglass now you look
like you're going into the eighth round
I do I take a swim but I'm still coming
you're still coming still coming you're
very Micky Ward yes and there are plenty
of fighters that look like this who came
still came Oh Katie for it there's
there's yeah I was when I was backstage
I grow even Donna we fought Robbie
Lawler yep well that was he couldn't see
he said I wasn't able to say daddy can
you see I can see a little bit get a
little dizzy
it itches pink it's just [ __ ] for the
stitches that right there look they
still use like the the thread stitching
they don't you the one you do things all
found oh you know look at Robbie Lawler
I mean I mean i roaring down oh my god
well that sir that changed everything
yes but sir you're very similar to that
especially on Wednesday Jesus I always
wanted to look like Rory MacDonald done
well there goes i I just think they
should stop fights
Robbie Lars but did but I can't believe
they're still using the thread stitching
why don't they use the dissolve so you
have to go back in
well I don't know because I'm not a
plastic surgeon you know what they
probably know better that they probably
know a little better that it's like
they're Diegans like shop not shut your
me like dr. diamond said he goes I go
you've done this before he goes a couple
times a couple of times it's so routine
for those guys we met with our business
guy Negus oh I saw your picture of Brian
and you know we're all surprised him but
you got the surgery he goes the only
people I know I get the surgery in high
school the Korean girls got it done
because they didn't yes that's a very
pious to be more round it's very precise
in Korea Korea in high school though
yeah it's the most popular so almost all
the kpop you would know yeah the kpop
fun women and men get their eyes I guess
as you guys everything yeah little
details well dude they have custom
implants for your jaw's for your for
your cheekbones
they have custom plenty implants for
everything
they have filler they have everything
you can imagine they well I mean see the
car - no one talks about it like no
one's like oh I got this done like
you'll just see a girl like oh I promise
like she black and blue problem is it
ruins thanks for you there was a girl in
Malibu I'm sitting there and with with
my friends and and there's a girl in
Malibu and I'm sitting there woman and
and she had a hi I looked at her
cheekbones and I went to her state she
just looked she was pretty she had
cheekbones and the woman next to me said
that's filler and I went no she goes
that and they all knew everybody at the
table who was from LA giggling I'm naive
- of course you are I have no because
it's so subtle and so good but there
there was a shiny there was a shiny Hill
perfectly right here where it did
wouldn't make sense but it looks great
so for me looks good I'm not man if
that's what you want to do I mean we
don't know how it's gonna look when
she's 40 well do you know what it's a
very popular surgery that people don't
know about men or women women one of the
most popular is they'll just young girls
they'll just lift your brows they'll
just go they'll just take your face and
they will go and what that does yeah you
don't need it at all
cat what they do is ring if you're if
you're not lucky like cat some women
have apparently this is this would be
the thing that they'll talk about they
have their eyebrows kind of fall well
yeah you know your forehead looks like
the belly of an earthworm that's exactly
right that's exactly right what else do
though we'll get into that in a second
that's bad in a second
I've been around know this lifted bang
they'll just bang they lift it up and
now you got and now you've got a little
bit more arts to your eyebrows now what
they have to do when they do that
however your if they got it they got to
gotta separate where do the skin from
here all the way down to here again not
in the operating room but this is what I
understand worth it and then you but you
heal and you're back you're that you can
do so much to your face in your body and
be back to normal and you're out for two
months yeah to put two months so I guess
these integrals take a week sometimes
like a bunch of pictures yeah oh she
looks surprised there you go yeah
she's like I don't know look like but it
but it but it does raise your eyebrows
make sure yeah yeah that's a very
popular thing you Brian
now the face it when he looks good yeah
he looks alert that bats a little yeah
with guys you got to be careful and for
whatever reason is with like John
Travolta's like cheeks and fillers look
at how good that looks amazing yeah huge
difference and then your neck and stuff
the facelift is what a 13-hour operation
I mean the doctor standing over you and
sitting over you for 10 hours 11 hours
think about that it insurance don't
cover any of this stuff right I don't
think so
well I think it's gonna be I think if
you have it done with a really good guy
it's gonna you're you're looking to fit
2 to 5 hours for the face the 50 60
grand
I can't imagine just having my eyes done
which isn't painful how much cost a
grand and to hunt 17 so yeah yeah no
especially in California you're looking
at yeah I would imagine me getting your
face lifted you want to go to the best
it's gonna be sad to man yeah it's your
fat a it so don't don't take shortcuts
delegate that you don't seek out the
cheapest one well when people go to just
random countries although a great place
to go for you like heart heart
transplant or what our heart surgery and
stuff is India India MD da Huebel if you
can get to Cuba has the best I don't
know if Cuba would do it but I remember
when up my dad would we grew up in the
summers in Venice and there was a
billboard for when LASIK first came out
and said LASIK two-for-one $79.99 and I
was like dad won't we why don't we could
go all bad I said like why don't we do
it he's like you're an idiot
do you have bad eyesight I had I had
LASIK oh you did oh yeah I don't know
mister we're contacting glasses now yeah
when did you get lazy right that was my
graduation gift for my dad when I could
graduate I've spoke out of here from
high school to cost on have done college
now you can see better see its really
get that surgery look cuz when you get
it done you'll blind for about 20
seconds bullshitting goes dark and then
it comes right back very scary oh it's
dude it's good they do it with a laser
and it's painless right yet you don't
read a number I then I know they have to
make a little incision just on the peel
back the opening
and then the laser goes into it's
[ __ ] astonishing that we can do that
I think human beings are complicated
machines and we are just we have the
we're gonna become excellent mechanics
and the more we learn about our own
machine then we will do anything you can
robot robots I would get an artificial
life if it was better and maybe let's
see like an eagle I don't know what's
like that you want I need water I'm so
sorry oh we go get it myself like the
Elon Musk thing where they want to put
that implant in your head I don't want
all that info dude I don't wanna I don't
then what's the point of learning
anything or reading or experiencing
things like it just land you can just
just any information like then there's
really no reason to argue either we both
know the exact facts to a tee there's no
argument there's no point of view which
that was just all why I had to write now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]